check this out it's from the New York
Post Bud Light sales reach new weekly
low following Dylan Mulvaney Fiasco
sales of Bud Light suffered their
steepest weekly drop I want to stress
this all for you please listen it has
been three months
three months later and the worst week so
far
28.5 drop
it's getting worse
yo it's supposed to be easing up three
months on I think this is brand death I
think you know the way I described it
earlier is that maybe this is where we
wrap a nice little bow around the Bud
Light story Dylan Mulvaney destroyed
Anheuser-Busch
that's wild look the the company exists
they'll make money and I'm not saying
that they just disappear off the face of
the Earth but I wonder if we might see a
Cascade effect that I talked about
before
three months on and sales are still
getting worse that's crazy and now
they're talking about so they're doing
another free beer giveaway
then Memorial Day now it's the fourth of
July coming up Bud Light is giving away
their beer for free now that's the get
well go broke man right understatement
yeah no I I think I think that's very
accurate and this entire past pride
month seems to have been a complete
disaster for the left which I've I very
much enjoyed part of why I think this
was such a massive and strategic error
for Bud Light is because not only were
they not selling a particularly
impressive product people aren't buying
Bud Light out of a sense of brand
loyalty people aren't buying Bud Light
because it's the best of the best people
are buying Bud Light because it's
inexpensive and it's what they have
access to but they also have access to
many other beer brands nobody who's
drinking Bud Light is picky about the
beer they're drinking right they could
have a product that's not from
Anheuser-Busch and enjoy it just as much
if not more so what they did is they
tried to force something incredibly
controversial onto people with a brand
that those people didn't need and had
very easily accessible alternatives to
yeah 30 or 40 years ago go beer was like
you didn't have that many choices right
there were a lot of it was centralized
then all of a sudden microbrews got
super popular and now you've got like 6
000 different choices you can stock your
bar with I mean yeah why would you ever
go for trash like take a look at this
from the USA Today it's bland Bud Light
offers 15 beer rebates for Fourth of
July weekend amid boycott declining
sales I chose as neutral of a source as
I can they mentioned that 15 packs of
the beer sell for less than fifteen
dollars it's not that they're
practically free they're giving you
money so they mention that some of these
15 packs are 12.99 in this article and
that you get a 15 rebate ladies and
gentlemen this is a beer company that's
giving away its beer for free when I
when I see that I'm looking at the stock
right look at this Anheuser-Busch
envelope in the past six months is down
5.72 in the past month they've actually
recovered 3.8 percent yo the market
often illogical a beer company that
doesn't sell beer it gives it away for
free that's something people apparently
have decided they should invest in well
and so this is something maybe some
people are just trying to buy the dip
they think it's going to get better I
can't imagine anything else explaining
that but I think that there's something
very
massive and catastrophic about this and
I mean catastrophic for them everyone's
been saying this is the best example of
a conservative boycott I've ever seen
this is one of the best examples of a
boycott in general I've ever seen when
was the last time you saw a brand that
was so heavily boycotted they started
giving their product away for free I've
never seen that happen before can you
guys think of any examples no of a
business that was losing customers at
such a rate that they started giving
their product away for free and people
still weren't taking it I've never seen
that happen before hey look their stock
has rebounded a couple of points in the
past week or so so that could be an
example of the people that sold so I'm
looking less for in May it dropped 20
percent they went from like 68 bucks to
52 or something like that and uh what
happened was a bunch of people probably
sold then the rest of the the world was
like uh oh and then they sold it dropped
so low then those original people that
sold bought back so yeah so they made
some money and they still have the same
amount of stock but then it dropped
again uh you know obviously people don't
want this stuff that's what I'm saying I
think maybe some people are trying to
buy the dip because they're thinking
this can't go on much longer yeah it's
not retail investment yes probably firms
and they're doing an analysis and
they're like okay we've seen it
stabilize it's been three months you
know we'll buy now and see what happens
people will get over it eventually you
know our stock price will go back up I
don't I don't know that they will I hope
they don't if I think they've really
done a number on themselves listen these
sale decline the sales decline at 28.5
percent
is with them offering these crazy
rebates right now you now they're
offering free beer they're like buy our
beer it's 12.99 for 15 pack you get a 15
rebate they call it practically free I'm
like yo they're giving you money they're
they're like okay up to 15 so I think
they're covering the cost so it is just
free so they're giving their beer away
for free
they're trying to stem the bleed
if they don't do this it would be down
50 so they're hoping that when after
they're doing this because they know
Fourth of July weekend their sales are
going to be in the gutter they've got to
do something to keep the number up so
that after next week
we can see in an improvement well yeah
and I'll also say I think that bad
Fourth of July numbers are going to be
particularly abysmal that is really
going to hurt their market value if they
don't see any kind of bump for the
holiday oh that's true and but I mean I
think the other point here is that even
with
free beer
free beer Fourth of July weekend
if any of you are going to barbecues
this weekend
who of you will be caught holding no a
Bud Light Trump I will make fun of
anyone who has it I will I will make fun
of anyone who who has it how about this
Shelby Talcott tweets Maga Mimosa the
featured drink at the NH Federation of
Republican women lilac luncheon where
Trump is scheduled to speak shortly and
there's uh Bud Light Budweiser and I
think is Stella is Stella man has her
friend I'm not sure I don't know but
they got Bud Light right there wouldn't
it be hysterical if Trump just started
trashing Bud Light while he was there
he's like I heard some people are saying
there was some Bud Light here like I
don't know quite frankly that would be
that would be the nail on the coffin we
went to an event in West Virginia I was
like a Republican's speech being given
and they had a a drink you know minibar
set up no Bud Light
and I walked up and I and the guy opened
the fridge and I could see Bud Light in
the fridge and I was like oh I see you
got Bud Light down there's like yeah we
don't have it out though because it's
like they have the stock if someone asks
for it was out to him but nobody's gonna
buy it and I'm like yeah okay so all the
Anheuser Bush product are pulled when we
did our events in in Texas we actually
told the bar no Anheuser-Busch products
they can't even do that at this
Republican event here's here's a
question here's a tough one for all of
you
um
Trump is guaranteed to win in 2024 but
you have to drink a Bud Light okay don't
do it you throw that butt like back you
let people take a picture of you holding
a Bud Light Tim pool if it messes
guaranteed to win I here's the thing
sorry no no I don't think you would
because he wouldn't pardon you for it
he'd be like he'd be like Tim Drake that
Bud Light it was awful
okay
anything about how you would drink Bud
Light
I will sacrifice for the greater good of
this country by drinking it means it
guaranteed Donald Trump the election yes
Stella is a b and Bev look at that
Stella
Tim I couldn't let you do it I said Tim
no there was there you know there have
been people who have been willing to
sacrifice everything to save everyone
Sheamus oh man look and you're saying
you if they said I was just asking you
quite frankly I want to see so hold on I
don't think Trump's gonna pardon you
they if they they come to you and say
Donald Trump okay a time traveler comes
uh-huh and he says Sheamus you
understand the butterfly effect right
okay I'm telling you right now if you
let me take this picture of you drinking
a Bud Light Trump will get elected you
wouldn't do it I would not do evil that
good might come of it laughs
yeah I would drink the baby would you do
a keg stand but like eggs and take it
off no Modelo that's fine though right I
don't know it's Modelo a b no but
seriously come on like I know it's
fantastic oh it's just good to know you
feel that way you know but I don't is
this like Trump sanctioned yeah modelo's
also ABN Dev no it's not the United
States it's constellation Brands oh fact
check we've got it on their website ab
and Bev Our Brands yeah outside outside
of the United States so in the U.S where
sales are skyrocketing it's owned by
constellation Brands and antitrust
lawsuit we do not own this delicious
beer in the U.S that's a disclaimer on
their way wow it says that it's
interesting okay so it did come on of
course everybody would if ever if if if
if there was some definitive proof the
Oracle of time the cia's time device you
could look into it and it was like if
everybody if all Trump supporters
started drinking Bud Light yeah I
wouldn't trust it it's the same device
they're only trying to get us to drink
Bud Light to boost their sales that's
why they're pulling this whole Trump
supporters discover an alien device that
can show them the future and they see a
possible future where if they all start
drinking Bud Light again Trump wins they
would dude Bud light's gonna sigh up us
into thinking that this is the truth
that's their marketing strand uh
strategy we we looked into the future
you it's the only way the only way for
Trump to win oh my goodness actually to
be honest though I think it would be the
opposite I think if conservatives
actually gave in and did not boycott
these Brands without a doubt Trump would
lose the fact that we're seeing so many
regular people and conservatives
actually sustain a boycott yeah so just
to me there will be the ground the
possible Ground Force for a trump
victory yeah well I think it's also just
indicative of the fact that your average
person isn't interested in having this
nonsense forced on them as we were
discussing earlier for a while people
were okay letting these things happen
far away from them where they wouldn't
have to see it but once you start
putting in their face they go you know
what if if it's either
um you stop doing this or it gets forced
on me I choose that you stop doing it
because I'm starting to feel like the
whole Live and Let Live thing was always
a lie thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time